and so I just want to say a couple
sentences about DNA sequencing just to
finish that up and so you remember this
slide from last lecture and remember the
way this Sanger technique works is to
set up four different reactions where
each reaction has a different one of
these dye deoxynucleotides okay so
there's four reactions each with
different dye deoxy and TP okay and I
just I brought along a gel that I ran a
while ago which is basically a it's from
a sequencing gel and you can I'll pass
this around so you can take a look at it
so the four different lanes for each
sample are the different dye deoxy
nucleotide reactions and what I want you
to notice as that's passing around and
you're looking at it is that the
different reactions with the different
dye Deoxys dye deoxynucleotides give
different patterns of DNA front fragment
lengths okay so there are different
patterns of fragment lengths and the
different patterns are based on the fact
this is based on the sequence the
sequence of the template okay and so if
we look at the example up here what
you'll see is that in this this banding
pattern for dye dye oxy TTP you see that
there's a really short fragment at the
bottom there and so that fragment
indicates that there must be an a in the
template sequence the next fragment up
would be this one in the dye deoxy gtp
lane and that indicates that one
nucleotide beyond this a is a si
position and so on and so forth such
that you can sort of order the fragments
and see which reaction has a fragment
and then read off a DNA sequence
okay so conceptually that's how you
would read off the sequence of a given
strand of DNA okay so you might be
wondering if now we just read off
sequence as a series of colors why am I
even introducing this technique okay and
the reason is because I think it's
important for you as potentially future
scientists to know that when you're
faced with a problem right how you might
discover something new okay and I sees
the Sanger method of DNA sequencing is a
really clever and elegant way in which
Fred Sanger solved the problem of DNA
sequencing and while we don't
necessarily do it that way today it
still illustrates a concept that's
important the concept of chain
termination and I think there's
something to be learned from this older
technique even if it's not exactly how
we sequence DNA today so for today's
lecture we're going to continue on our
quest to basically clone a gene that's
responsible for a disease
and so we started this in the last
lecture and I guess to one thing we
would want to start with is a disease so
I'm going to introduce to you now a
disease called aniridia and in order to
clone the gene for a disease it has it
has to be a heritable disease in this
case okay because we're going to use
linkage analysis to identify it so
aniridia is a disease that's an eye
disease in humans it's a rare eye
disease so I want to show you an example
of this eye disease the ID the way this
disease manifests itself is it's
basically the affected individual has an
eye that is lacking an iris
okay so I'm going to show you what this
looks like if you're squeamish or don't
like like weird eyes and you don't want
to look you can look away okay but I
will show you affected phenotype in 3 2
1
ok everyone looking who wants to see
weird eyes ok good so that is an
individual that has aniridia and also
this one so you see there's no clear
iris in these eyes ok and this disease
is associated with other abnormalities
of the eye that severely impair vision
okay and this is a inherited disease and
this is a pedigree from a family or
series of family is where the disease is
propagating and so anyone have
suggestion as to what mode of
inheritance this is
anyone want to rule a mode out Rachel do
you have an idea
[Music]
okay so let's take excellent dominant so
if it was excellent dominant then this
male would have an X chromosome with the
dominant allele of the disease and
should only pass it to his females so I
don't think that it would necessarily be
excellent dominant okay anyone else have
an idea yeah Georgia autosomal dominant
I like autosomal dominant so in this
case you see you have an individual with
the disease and they marry into a family
with no history of the disease a one
thing I'll point out for many of these
diseases they're extremely rare so if
you see sort of a family tree where
there's no instance of the disease if
it's a rare disease it's likely that
these individuals are not carriers okay
and so in this case if you assume that
this person doesn't have any form of the
is in a carrier for the disease then
this cross here resulting in about half
of the individuals affected with the
disease that would be a characteristic
of an autosomal dominant disease so
everyone understand my logic yes Carlos
I think they're deceased yes okay so
let's say you have a pedigree you have
pedigrees you're able to try to link
this marker to our the disease phenotype
with various molecular markers which we
discussed in last week's lectures then
you're on the way to performing a
process which is known as positional
gene cloning and what positional gene
cloning is is it's basically cloning a
gene and a allele that's responsible for
a disease based on its position in the
genome is positioned in a particular
chromosomal region okay so it's
basically cloning a gene
based on its chromosomal position or its
chromosome position okay in the first
step of positional gene cloning would be
to establish maybe what chromosome it's
on and that a straightforward way to do
this as we've basically been discussing
almost from when I started lecturing is
to create some sort of linkage map or do
linkage mapping to identify in the case
of humans molecular markers that this
disease allele is linked to okay and
remember on last week's lecture we we
talked about a number of different
polymorphisms that are present in a
human human genome that we can use to
establish linkage with a given phenotype
in this case it's a human disease okay
and we talked about this example for a
microsatellite marker and in this case
we talked through this example of how
this dominant allele P is linked to this
microsatellite allele m double prime
because if you look at the pedigree here
all of the affected individuals here
contain this n double prime size
fragment for this microsatellite another
thing to notice here is you can see that
this this couple has been faithful to
each other because basically each of the
children have an allele from the father
and an allele from the mother okay so
you can see that type of you can see
that using this type of molecular marker
as well okay so you establish linkage so
linking linkage mapping establishes the
chromosome position of a given allele
and the gene
okay in this chromosome position sort of
gets you maybe in the right country but
you still have a long way before you get
to the specific street address okay and
so you have to then sort of narrow it in
to identify a smaller region of the
chromosome that could possibly contain
this gene okay and so what you would do
is go from this linkage map where you
maybe identify the position of this gene
within a couple map units to this next
resolution of map called a physical map
okay so we go from the linkage position
to the physical map of the chromosome
and the physical map as the name implies
is when you have physical pieces of DNA
that are present in this region of the
chromosome okay so the physical map
means you have cloned so recombinant
pieces of DNA cloned pieces of DNA which
encompass a given chromosome region so
these are encompassing a chromosome
region okay so how would you get a piece
of DNA that sort of is in this region
how would you start how would you start
fishing for that DNA so you've gone
through the process of the mate of
linkage you've identified sort of a
polymorphism that is linked to the
disease allele how would you go from
there to getting a physical piece of DNA
that is present in that region of the
chromosome so let's think back to Jeremy
did you have an idea
start by using meteor and what PC what
primers I guess would you use for the
PCR okay so Jeremy is saying if you knew
the sequence right and I guess if you're
doing this micro satellite analysis
right
you had primers that recognized the
sequence at a given genomic position so
you actually know something about the
sequence because of this polymorphism so
you can use that knowledge to then look
for this sequence and you can even look
for the micro satellite in a DNA library
okay okay so you have cloned pieces of
DNA and you're gonna start with and I'm
gonna swap this your starting position
could be one of these polymorphisms in
the sequence around it which you already
know okay so let's say you had this
microsatellite marker you could then
what I'm drawing here is a piece of
genomic DNA so this is genomic DNA okay
and it's I'm just drawing the insert
this would be recombinant DNA it will be
present in some vector or plasmid but if
you can identify the sequence that
contains this microsatellite marker then
you would have the microsatellite but
also the surrounding DNA okay so that
sort of anchors you at a given position
now you don't know if your gene is in
that piece of DNA but you know that it's
linked and so it should be around that
piece of DNA somewhere okay and so you
know it's unlikely your genes gonna be
on this small piece of DNA that's close
this is probably just a few KB and you
could still be very far away from this
but that served as a starting point from
which you can go from to get more and
more pieces of DNA such that eventually
you have a bunch of pieces of DNA that
are going to span the entire region okay
so the way you would identify other
pieces of DNA is you could start with a
piece of DNA maybe at the end of this
insert and look for other inserts that
are not identical to this piece that
also can contain this piece here so that
might get you a piece that's overlapping
but extends farther than your initial
piece okay so now you've moved slightly
farther away from your starting point
which is this starting polymorphism then
you could choose maybe another DNA
sequence here and look for a piece of
DNA that again is extending a bit
farther out and so you can see how
iteratively you can get farther and
farther away from this starting point
that you know your gene is linked to and
this process of going sort of piece by
piece and clone by clone away from a
starting position is known as a
chromosome walk okay and you can do this
by directionally so you could also start
with a sequence of DNA here and look for
a clone that goes the other way and you
can see on my slide up there you can see
that in this case they've taken a one
map unit region of the chromosome and
they're illustrating physical pieces of
DNA that are overlapping that encompass
this entire region okay so this could be
much bigger than the amount of DNA that
would fit in one of these clones in the
bacteria but by sort of identify
overlapping clones you get the entire
region and what this is called here
because these pieces of DNA are
contiguous with each other the
is known as a contig okay so yeah Jeremy
you could sequence it or you could use a
technique that I'm gonna talk about at
the end of my lecture which I'll come
back to yeah so nowadays you'd probably
just sequence it and then maybe look for
that in another clone but even before we
could sequence DNA sort of in entire
genomes you could do that type of
experiment by using a technique called
hybridization which I'll come back to
okay so the question in this chromosome
walk then becomes how do you know when
to stop okay because you could do this
for a very long time but it might not be
useful right so you have to know when to
stop and you need to know when you
arrive at the gene that you're
interested in which would be the gene
that is responsible for the disease okay
so another way to phrase this question
is how do you know when you have an
interesting gene on one of these
fragments so let's say this is an
interesting gene here how do you
identify interesting genes okay so now
let's talk about identifying interesting
genes anyone have an idea for how they
were what criteria they would use to
define a gene as being interesting here
I mean one could say that all genes are
interesting right if it's a gene it's
interesting right so how might we define
whether or not there's a gene even there
right it could be there could be a gene
how would you define a gene can someone
define for me a gene yeah
miles is it miles no Malik okay
that would create a story
[Music]
so you'd look for a piece of DNA that
has a start and a stop codon so you look
for an open reading frame basically yeah
you could look for an open reading frame
and so I totally agree with Malik there
and another criteria you could use is if
it's encoding a protein at some point it
also must have been transcribed as an
mRNA okay and there are some genes that
are transcribed as RNA but don't make a
protein and they're often involved in
coding or in regulation of gene
expression okay so I'm gonna do I'm
gonna say is it transcribed so is there
some transcript that's made and
specifically is it transcribed in the
tissue that were interested in okay so
if we're talking about aniridia right we
might be looking for genes that are
being expressed or transcribed
specifically in eyes right you're
looking for something that might be
expressed in the eye if it's not
expressed in the eye that genes going to
be much less interesting to you because
the phenotype of aniridia is clearly in
the eye okay okay what might be some
other criteria here well one criteria
might be is there a conserved gene that
has an interesting function that's maybe
similar to the disease related phenotype
okay so is there a conserved gene
with an interesting function okay and to
take this example of aniridia right
let's say you're doing this chromosome
walk and you identify a gene maybe you
sequence part of this clone you get a
string of sequence and you realize that
the sequence that you get is related to
a gene from a model organism and maybe
that gene is called eyeless right then
if you've identified a region of
sequence in the human in the human
genome
that's mapping to an eye disease gene
and you find out there in that region
there's a conserved gene called eyeless
you this might be a very interesting
gene for you okay so I list is a gene so
here's a normal fly you see it has that
bright red eye the eyelift gene when
mutated results in a fly that now just
doesn't have a white eye but has no eye
altogether okay so it turns out that the
aniridia gene is the homologue of the
eyeless gene and flies okay that's not
how it was identified initially but now
nowadays there's a lot of information in
model organisms and so if you're sort of
trying to identify a gene and you see
that there's a gene in the neighborhood
you're looking at with a function that's
related to a gene like eyeless which has
a clear sort of analogy in terms of
phenotype then that's going to increase
your interest in that gene okay so I'm
going to come back to this a point here
which is how do we determine whether a
piece of DNA that's on one of these
inserts that we're getting as we walk
across the chromosome how do we know
whether it is transcribed or not okay
and to get at this I'm going to
introduce you to a concept which is
important in and of itself which is the
idea of
see DNA okay so cDNA and specifically
I'm gonna show you how one would make a
cDNA library which is basically a
library of different cDNAs and so what
cDNA is as shown up there on my slide a
cDNA is complementary DNA okay
its complementary DNA meaning that is
the complement of an mRNA transcript
okay
this DNA is the complement of an RNA or
mRNA transcript hey one thing to watch
out for is it's not complimentary DNA
okay so this is MIT this is an O
complement zone so I don't want to see
any complementary DNA okay all right so
let's think about complementary DNA so
remember we've talked about the central
dogma and how DNA encodes for RNA which
encodes for protein and so the
information flows from DNA through RNA
to protein okay but there are some
specialized cases in biology where this
information flow is reversed okay so
there can be a reverse of information
flow where information flows from RNA to
DNA okay so that's pretty cool
where does that happen well there are
viruses such as retroviruses one example
of a retrovirus is HIV
and the virus life cycle is G gnome is a
single-stranded RNA molecule and the
life cycle is the virus is that inserts
into the host the host genome which is
double-stranded DNA for a retrovirus to
do that it needs to take its RNA genome
and make double-stranded DNA in order
for it to insert okay so this is an
example in biology which is basically
breaking the rules that we talked to you
about earlier in the semester okay
also there are retrotransposons which do
this similar process going from an RNA
molecule to double-stranded DNA okay so
this is a specialized case and it's
interesting and we can take advantage of
it to basically clone and identify mRNA
transcripts okay so I'm gonna tell you
how to make complementary DNA and I'll
go through a series of steps the first
step is we want to make complementary
DNA of mRNA so we need a way to purify
the mRNA so anyone have any idea how to
purify mRNA first we could maybe draw an
RNA molecule here what are some salient
features of mature mRNA yeah Carlos yep
it'll have a 5 prime cap anything else
Jeremy they'll have a five prime cap in
a poly a tail I'm gonna take advantage
mostly of the poly a tail here so here
we have a poly a tail okay how might we
use that poly a tail to purify mRNA
Natalie
mmm-hmm what sequence would you use yes
so Natalie has suggested using poly T
which she said would stick to this poly
a tail because of base pair
hybridization okay so let's say we have
a bead or some type of resin with poly d
TS hanging off of it so I'll draw a few
of them but you'd have maybe a lot of
them sticking off okay so you have a
bead with pieces of DNA all of which are
poly DT hanging off of it and then these
poly d TS if you add cytoplasm from
cells the mRNA in that cytoplasm is
going to stick to this poly DT bead and
it will stick with a higher affinity
than other things that are non
specifically sticking to the beads and
you can wash these beads with buffer and
salt to get rid of everything that's non
specifically sticking to the bead and
then you're left with just a bead that's
enriched with mRNA which is what was
specifically sticking to this okay so
you could purify your purifying the mRNA
based on its affinity for a poly DT okay
so then you're gonna have an enrichment
of mRNA in your sample and so then once
you have your RNA you're gonna want to
somehow go from RNA to DNA okay so the
next step will involve somehow going
from RNA to DNA so let's draw our piece
of RNA here here's our RNA it has a poly
a tail so its mRNA
there's five-prime okay so now we need
to take advantage of a trick we can
still take advantage of poly DT because
we can use this as a primer because
polymerase is usually require some sort
of primer and a three prime hydroxyl in
order to extend now can we use DNA
polymerase to extend this primer Jeremy
is shaking his head no why exactly so
Jeremy is saying is DNA polymerase is a
DNA dependent DNA polymerase okay
DNA polymerase can only use this if this
is DNA here okay so we need a different
type of enzyme essentially in order to
make DNA from RNA and luckily molecular
biologists actually one of whom was here
at MIT discovered this type of enzyme
and it's called reverse transcriptase
reverse transcriptase this is an enzyme
that's encoded by retroviruses in order
to make double-stranded DNA from RNA and
that allows the retrovirus to insert
into the host genome okay
and what reverse transcriptase is is
it's an RNA dependent DNA polymerase
okay so it takes RNA as its substrate
and then synthesizes DNA on the opposite
strand okay so this is an RNA dependent
DNA polymerase okay so if you add
reverse transcriptase to mRNAs that have
these poly DT primers then what you get
is a new strand which is DNA here this
is a strand
DNA and then you have a strand of RNA
opposite it okay so this is at this step
you have a dna-rna hybrid okay so this
is a dna-rna hybrid see reveal some more
of this this is the process which I'm
basically outlining on the board so then
you want double-stranded DNA so you
don't want this strand of RNA that's
down here so you have to get get rid of
it so you would degrade the RNA and this
is done using another enzymatic activity
which is derived from reverse
transcriptase which has termed RNase H
activity so you can add an enzyme RNase
H which RNase H takes this DNA RNA
hybrids and degrades the RNA part of it
okay so this is going to degrade the RNA
strand and if you degrade the RNA strand
then you're left with a single strand of
DNA okay so you have single-stranded DNA
here and now what you need to do is to
synthesize the second strand of DNA so
you need second strand synthesis and so
you need again a primer in order to sort
of prime the synthesis here so they're
very variety of ways to do this you can
add some type of hairpin which is five
prime here and three prime here and then
you can use either DNA polymerase or
reverse transcriptase which also can be
a DNA dependent DNA polymerase to
transcribe this strand here okay
so again you add a polymerase and now
you've gone and you've generated a
double-stranded DNA okay so everyone see
how we've gone from an mRNA transcript
and we've we've kind of done the reverse
of everything we just told you in the
election of the first half of the course
because we've gone from RNA and we've
made DNA okay but this isn't be really
useful because now we have a stable
piece of DNA that we can clone into a
plasmid and we have a record of this
transcript being present in our sample
and we can sort of propagate that on and
on so we've cloned it okay all right
what's going to be special about this
piece of DNA versus a piece of genomic
DNA Natalie yes so Natalie suggested it
doesn't have introns and that's totally
right so this is not like genomic DNA
and what Natalie said is because mRNA is
processed is the introns are spliced out
such the mature mRNA only has the exons
and so this piece of complementary cDNA
is gonna have no introns how else is it
different
yeah Jeremy it's not gonna have a
promoter yes Carmen you might see the
Polly you might see a Polly a and T
sequence in the cDNA yes that's true
okay so you might have Polly a polity
I'm gonna focus on the other part from
there's gonna be no promoter enhancer
regulatory sequences basically it's got
no sequence that's not transcribed right
this is the DNA is only going to have
the part of the gene that was physically
transcribed by the RNA polymerase
originally okay so no non transcribed
regions known it non transcribed regions
and Carmen's absolutely right you will
also have possibly a poly a or poly T
sequence okay so when you get these C
DNA's you might have you have more than
one mRNA in a sample like a cytoplasmic
extract so you're gonna prime you're
gonna make multiple cdnas and different
C DNA's will reflect different
transcripts that are present in your
sample okay so you could have one clone
that's one gene another clone that's a
different gene and another clone that's
another gene and you could have
thousands of clones of these different
DNA's what's going to be special about
what what types of genes are you gonna
get for I guess different tissues are
they going to be the same or not yeah
Carlos
exactly you're not gonna see if you've
prepared a tissue and there's no gene
being what if one gene was not expressed
or transcribed in that tissue you will
not get a cDNA for that particular gene
in your library okay so the
representation of genes the
representation of genes in a cDNA
library is totally dependent on what
genes are being expressed okay so this
representation is going to be
proportional to the expression level and
the more genes the more a gene is
expressed in a given tissue the more
copies of cDNA for that gene you would
see in the library okay so those really
a proportionality between the number of
clones in the library in the expression
level of the gene we're sort of in the
most extreme case if this gene is not
expressed at all you're not going to see
it represented at all in the cDNA
library okay and then a corollary to
this statement is that if you make cDNA
cDNA libraries from different cell types
or different tissue types the cDNA
libraries are going to be different
between those different types of sources
of mRNA okay so in other words different
tissues give you different cDNA
again okay so there's the process so I
went through most of the smile so you're
asking if you grind up like an entire
organism and if you get a cDNA from that
library could you tell if it's expressed
in like all different cell types it's
because even if you have one cell type
that expresses a gene right if you grind
up the entire organism then you're gonna
have some mRNA that represents that gene
so I don't think it would be as an
effective measure to determine the
ubiquity of the expression of a given
gene but in just a minute I'm gonna give
you a tool that would allow you to
answer the exact question that you're
asking okay any other questions about
the cDNA library okay so I just wanted
to mention that come back to this
example I gave on the identification of
the human cdk gene so remember we
started with yeast that were were
mutants they had temperature-sensitive
mutants and we transformed these mutants
with a library but I didn't really tell
you what the library was it was in fact
the cDNA library from humans that was
transformed into yeast okay and that's
me as yeast genes for the most part are
they don't have a lot of introns and so
the yeast machinery is not able to
splice out the human introns and human
genes okay
and so this was done with a human cDNA
library which then encoded one of which
encoded the human cdk gene and that
allowed Paul nurse to discover the piece
of DNA that encoded for the human cdk
okay so I just wanted to kind of retro
actively go back and sort of tell you
how that experiment was done
okay so now I'm gonna get to my final
point for this lecture which is this
final technique which will allow us to
determine whether or not a transcript is
expressed in a single cell type or
ubiquitously through an organism and
this involves a technique which is known
as hybridization and what hybridization
is is if you're starting with a piece of
DNA right you don't need to know its
sequence in order to determine whether
there are sequences that are similar or
identical to it
okay this hybridization is basically if
you have some sequence and it's
single-stranded such that you have a DNA
backbone but you have base pairs that
are able to pair with their
complementary bases and you can use a
piece of single-stranded DNA like this
and you can label it such that if the
labeled piece sticks to another piece
that has identical or similar sequence
you'll be able to visualize it in some
way okay so this is called you're
looking for things that an eel or
hybridize to a particular specific
sequence so you don't need to know the
sequence a priori okay you just need to
have this physical piece of DNA and you
can use this single stranded piece of
DNA to then fish for similar sequences
okay so we could take a piece of DNA
here maybe that's in a gene and we could
fish through a cDNA library to try to
identify a cDNA clone that has sequence
identity to that piece of DNA okay and
the way this is done is to take a cDNA
library so each of these colonies here
would Express or have a different clone
of see
you can then take a nitrocellulose
filter put it on this plate which would
stick the bacteria in place to that
filter and you could then lyse the
bacteria and denature the DNA and then
the DNA is stuck to the figure but now
to the filter but now it's
single-stranded you can then add your
probe which is labeled and look for the
colonies that this probe sticks to and
that would then identify a particular
cDNA which would identify whether or not
a piece of DNA is expressed in a given
tissue type okay so everyone see how how
that would work so in addition to doing
this on a nitrocellulose filter you can
also do this in a tissue and that's
known as in situ hybridization and in
this case an in situ hybridization
you're searching for mRNA in a section
of fixed tissue
okay and I have an example from this
paper here which is the paper this
cloned in this paper was the cloning of
the aniridia gene and they identified a
gene of interest which is called pak six
now and they basically used a piece of
DNA that they thought was interesting
and they did in situ hybridization in
the in organism in this case you see an
eye this is an eye here and the labeled
pack six is labeled in yellow and you
can see how this transcript is present
throughout the entire eye right and the
way you would see if it's tissue
specific is you'd look in other tissues
and you wouldn't see this yellow label
so that's how would you that's how you
would determine if it's expressed in a
specific tissue or ubiquitously
throughout an organism okay so this pax6
gene so i was gonna ask what do you
think would happen if you hyper activate
pack six in humans and this is one idea
but actually i'm I just made that up or
Stanley made that up but actually
Stanley never in fact mentioned whether
or not Cyclops is a pack six mutant but
we can do a different type of experiment
which might be more ethical which is we
know there's a fly gene that's
homologous to pack six and what we can
do is in flies is we can ectopic ly
express this eyeless gene in non eye
tissues and see what happens okay so
this is pretty wild this is my Halloween
image of the class so this is a fly
where I list has been expressed all over
its body okay so here you see there's an
eye it's normal I here you can see
there's now another eye growing in the
front of its head you can see here's an
eye growing on this flies back and you
can see the legs their eyes there's eye
tissue all over the legs of this fly
okay so this pax6 gene which is
conserved from flies to humans
the master regulator of eye development
okay and at least in flies if you have
topically express this in other parts of
the body you get an eye I should say
these are not functional eyes the don't
hook up to the brain the same way the
normal eye does so it's not like this
fly can like see out of the back of its
head okay that's it I'm done and good
luck on your exam on Wednesday we will
see you here
you